[Musique]
bonsoir à tous mercredi 15 mai bienvenue
dans le 7-8 journal de tv 78 de ses 26
minutes pour faire le tour de
l'actualité locale et régionale voici
les titres de cette édition les futurs
espions formés dans les yvelines
sciences po saint germain vient de
lancer son diplôme sur le renseignement
et de menaces globales c'est une
première en france
un cursus de 160 heures avec des cours
théorique mais aussi pratique
invité de ce journal yves delpuech
responsable à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
de solidarités nouvelles face au chômage
l'association a publié un rapport qui
met en avant les impacts négatifs du
chômage sur la santé des demandeurs
d'emploi nous parlerons également des
actions déployées par snc enfin la suite
de notre focus sur le football féminin à
quelques semaines de l'ouverture de la
coupe du monde en france ce soir état
des lieux de la pratique dans les clubs
du département
le district des yvelines compte environ
6% de licenciées féminines
et puis toujours au chapitre sport nous
présenterons dans cette édition à la
26ème le 26e trophée sport passion qui
se tient demain c'est au golf de
feucherolles c'est donc une formation
inédite en france un diplôme sur le
renseignement et les nouvelles menaces
il a été lancé officiellement par
sciences po saint germain en laye en
partenariat avec l'académie du
renseignement le cursus qui débutera en
octobre sera ouvert aux étudiants est
mais aussi aux agents déjà en activité
les images de mélanie poker le
renseignement un monde plein de
fantasmes alimenté notamment par les
nombreuses séries télévisées sur le
sujet c'est pour ouvrir le secteur vers
les domaines universitaires que science
pause saint germain en laye propose
cette formation le dira m comprenait
diplômes d'établissement sur le
renseignement et les menaces globales a
été développé avec l'académie du
renseignement saint germain en laye
c'est un jeune institut d'études
politiques mais qui en son sein 10
passes d'une équipe très engagé sur ces
questions de sécurité de violence de
lutte contre le terrorisme
puisque nous sommes associés à un
laboratoire de recherche qui s'appelle
le 16 10
qui est très orienté sur les questions
de sécurité les questions les questions
pénales de façon générale le diplôme est
organisé en 6 sessions de trois jours
consécutifs qui se dérouleront d'octobre
à mars
une formation de 160 environ divisé en
trois grands modules un module sur les
menaces contemporaines un module sur le
renseignement et un module sur les
pratiques et les techniques et chaque
module comporte quatre courts quatre
petits cours d'eau avec des cours sur
l'économie du crime organisé un cours
sur le djihadisme salafistes un cours
sur la violence politique et la
radicalisation un cours sur la cyber
menaces ces cours seront donnés par des
professeurs d'université et des
professionnels du milieu même diversité
de profils chez les élèves formation
initiale pour les étudiants bac +4
formation en continu pour les agents des
services de renseignement déjà en poste
c'est une manière pour tout
professionnel d'avoir un éclairage
universitaire bénéficier des derniers
résultats de la recherche
une vingtaine d'étudiants proposera
chaque année la promotion du diplôme les
inscriptions à la formation sont
ouvertes jusqu'au 28 juin prochain une
journée pour mettre en avant
l'innovation springs se dérouler
aujourd'hui c'était sur le campus de
centrale supélec à gif-sur-yvette
deuxième édition de cet événement
organisé par l'établissement public
d'aménagement paris-saclay dont fait
partie saint quentin en yvelines
les acteurs de l'innovation de la
recherche et du développement économique
se sont donné rendez vous au programme
business table-ronde présentation un
territoire de paris saclay où
s'effectuent 15% de la recherche
publique et privée en france
et les propos sont recueillis par
nicolas landry vous savez qu'on est un
cluster un des clusters mondiaux de
l'innovation qu'on a dénommé paris
saclay il n'avait qu'une très grande et
c'est l'occasion de montrer les
l'innovation de créer les relations
entre laboratoires de recherche
chercheurs start up et monde économique
pour favoriser l'innovation le rôle de
le pea c'est d'accompagner tout ça et de
vieillir de maximiser les possibles de
l'innovation et c'est un événement
important en terme de visibilité nous
vous proposerons un reportage complet
sur cette journée de demain
le 7-8 journal piloter un appareil sans
être à bord c'est ce que permet un drone
ce mardi le groupe d'affaires saint
quentinois hhbc proposait conférence
démonstration test à ses membres au
coeur du circuit jean pierre beltoise à
trappes et retours avec mélanie poquet
nicolas landry surveiller un site
identifié un intrus grâce à une caméra
thermique des actions parfois invisibles
à l'oeil possible grâce aux drones un
appareil radio commandé comme ceux
développés par le groupe france et
gorron ont montré la capacité et surtout
l'utilité du drone aujourd'hui on sait
qu'un drone forcément et moins chère à
l'utilisation comme hélicoptère et ça de
nombreuses directions l'ont compris
depuis longtemps c'est pour ça qu'elles
font appel à nous puisqu'aujourd'hui 1h
d'hélicoptères son prix d'utilisation
varie entre 1000 et 2000 euros alors que
le drone ne lui coûtent moins de 100
euros à l'utilisation alors plusieurs
membres du happy hour business club ont
pu tester ces appareils une conférence
était proposé ce mardi sur le circuit
jean-pierre beltoise
je trouve ça semble d'utilisation parce
que voilà il ya un je tique un joystick
gauche pour aller à droite et à gauche
un juge 3 2 pour avancer en arrière
c'est facile à prendre mais je pense que
c'est une utilisation qui se substitue
pas à l'être humain mais qui vient en
complément et en aide surtout par
exemple dans le domaine de recherche de
personnes qui est un secteur qui
m'intéresse et que pour lequel je fais
moi-même cette activité à titre de
loisir avec avec un chien en france
toute personne souhaitant piloter un
drone de plus de 800 grammes doit passer
un certificat deux pilotes de loisirs on
va parler à présent emploi et santé dans
ce journal car vous allez le voir les
deux sujets sont liés bonsoir yves
delpuech
bonsoir vous êtes le responsable du
groupe de saint quentin en yvelines de
solidarités nouvelles face au face au
chômage pardon cette association lutte
contre le chômage et l'exclusion dans
toute la france et vous deviez nous
présenter un colloque qui allait se
dérouler demain il a été finalement
annulée mais ça n'empêche pas d'aborder
cette thématique en plateau la santé des
demandeurs d'emploi un enjeu de santé
publique c'est l'objet d'un dernier
rapport publié par votre association qui
met en avant notamment les conséquences
négatives du chômage sur la santé des
demandes
emploi avant qu'on présente ses
conséquences négatives
vous qui êtes au contact de ces
demandeurs d'emploi y sont en souffrance
sur sept est souvent en souffrance
et souvent c'est de la souffrance cachée
c'est à dire qu'on se cache derrière des
grandes théories des grands mots des
pour ne pas avouer qu'on est en
souffrance
en plus on voit ces personnes là qui
vont à pôle emploi et qui ne veulent
surtout pas avoir l'air malade pour ne
pas dire je vais pas pouvoir prendre un
emploi à cause des souffrances que je
ressens alors nous allons dire que dans
ce sens là aussi la mauvaise santé
peut-être des demandeurs d'emploi va les
exclure face à l'emploi c'est ça cela
peut marcher dans ce sens là quel sens
cela fonctionne
est ce que c'est la mauvaise santé qui
va pas lui qui va un petit peu
traumatisé les gens pour rechercher un
emploi puisque c'est finalement le
chômage qui va à la main dans le compte
des conséquences négatives sur le
demandeur d'emploi donc et en plus c'est
ce que nous nous appelons un problème à
bas bruit dans la mesure où personne ne
veut en parler pour l'emploi ce n'est
pas son affaire puisque lui c'est de
reclasser les gens du soudan dans
l'activité économique et pas de
s'occuper de leur santé
et quand on va travailler avec la caisse
primaire d'assurance maladie le chômage
n'est pas son problème elle regarde le
problème du côté simplement maladie et
par recherche d'emploi c'est aussi
peut-être dans l'est dans les médias
c'est un mal invisible aujourd'hui ce
sujet de la santé des demandeurs dans
les actes eux mans il ya peu d'études ya
peu de gens qui se
qui s'ennuient en tissu qui regarde un
petit peu tous ces problèmes et même le
corps médical n'a pas été formé à à
gérer ce genre de problème vous êtes
vous dresser dans ce rapport des effets
négatifs que peut avoir le chômage sur
les demandeurs d'emploi ces deux ils
sont plusieurs ordres ses effets
négatifs qu'elle a pensé ses effets
juillet plusieurs il ya plusieurs
classes si on peut dire
la première d'abord c'est l'aspect
psychologique on y reviendra peut-être
la deuxième c'est l'hygiène de vie qui
se dégrade
la troisième c'est on rentre vraiment
dans dur de sujets avec tous les
problèmes médicaux les abandons de soins
et enfin ce qui arrive est un petit peu
plus tard mais qui arrive quand même les
problèmes financiers qui arrive qu'il y
en ait fait perdre heures dont vous avez
parlé c'est finalement il ya un
phénomène de renoncement aux soins qui
est fait par les faits par les talibans
dans un premier temps la visite chez
l'ophtalmologiste
on attendra un petit peu et puis cette
dent qui commence à me faire mal bas
c'est cher s'il faut que je sois sinon
on attend un petit peu les choses
s'accumulent petit à petit et en plus on
arrive dans un problème autres quels
problèmes financiers parce que pendant
un certain temps qu'on vous êtes au
chômage vous bénéficiez de la mutuelle
si on peut dire que vous aviez en
entreprise le mutuelle tombe il faut
trouver d'autres mutuelles
les revenus sont moins importants donc
là on y va on évite de prendre une
mutuelle ou non prendre mutuel à minimum
qu'ils remboursent à minimum aussi donc
c'est c'est l'effet boule de neige qui
arrive vient nous fera space vous
l'évoquiez c'est l'aspect psychologique
ya pas de queue de la souffrance
physique c'est aussi psychique ya un
aspect psychologique bon
d'abord il ya le deuil de l'emploi ce
comme toute rupture entraîne un certain
nombre de perturbations
via la dépression qui arrive derrière il
ya aussi la révolte mais ça je vais dire
que la révolte ça peut être positif
c'est qu'on n'ait déjà dans le rouge
dans le rebond quand on se révolte
et puis il ya autre chose qui devait qui
très grave c'est le la perte de repères
sociaux c'est-à-dire quand on quand on
est en activité
on a le droit d'avoir des loisirs quand
on se retrouve au chômage
on a mauvaise conscience de prendre des
loisirs ce qui est complètement aberrant
dans la mesure où pour son ressortir du
lot il faut continuer à vivre le plus
normalement possible c'est à dire qu'il
faut continuer à aller au cinéma et au
théâtre à recevoir et aller chez des
amis bon alors bien sûr chez les amis 7
a retrouvé quelque chose comment ça se
passe tu va rebondir même si c'est fait
dans un dans un esprit de faire rebondir
la personne la personne ne perçoit
parfois très mal le rapport n'est pas
que dans le constat il l'édifice idées
des propositions c'est ça pour qu'il y
ait des améliorations sur sur ce sujet
quel exemple telle piste en tout cas
alors on voudrait des références de
l'association ou voudraient déjà
travailler un petit peu sur le problème
de la mutuelle et delà de l'accès aux
soins
c'est à dire qu'on a beaucoup
d'organismes qui permettent quand même
aux gens de se soigner pour des sommes
très modique
nous connaissons bien sur le territoire
de saint quentin en yvelines ni ps qui
peut apporter des soins gratuits pour
les publics ou à l'institut de promotion
de la santé qui peut apporter des soins
gratuitement aux personnes qui sont en
difficulté il ya les fameuses les femmes
ces crs les comités communaux d'action
sociale dans les mairies qui peuvent
aussi apporter des solutions
et puis on est en train d'essayer de
travailler aussi avec les assureurs avec
un grand a
pour qu'ils fassent des propositions
avec des tarifs demandeurs d'emploi un
dernier mot parce qu'on arrive à la fin
de cet entretien sur le groupe de saint
quentin en yvelines je voulais qu'on
termine par ce groupe une petite
présentation combien de bénévoles voilà
sont actifs sur sur cette langue
combien de personnes vous accompagnait
alors sur saint quentin en yvelines on
était une
une trentaine de bénévoles regroupés sur
un seul groupe qui s'appelait saint
quentin en yvelines devant le tout
l'ampleur que prend le groupe ou n'a
fait d accueil plus dispersées c'est à
dire qu'on a un accueil sur le 50 ans
centre de saint quentin historique un
accueil maintenant sur la plaine de
versailles qui comprend plaisir ville
près du clec et un accueil du côté de
chevreuse avec magny les hameaux
avec magny les hameaux et puis chevreuse
et la verrière et nous accompagnons à
peu près 140 à 150 de demandeurs
d'emploi par an avec un taux de retour à
l'emploi mais ça on n'est pas un seul
n'est pas que nous c'est parce que nous
avons un un plateau très dynamique
un taux de retour à l'emploi de 80% des
personnes à neuf mois merci il veut
delpech pour tous ces éléments je
rappelle que vous êtes le responsable de
ce groupe de saint quentin en yvelines
pour solidarités nouvelles face au
chômage avant que je puisse tous et
récupérer un petit peu de ma voix ce
sujet à quelques semaines du lancement
de la coupe du monde de football féminin
nous poursuivons bien sûr est notre
dossier de la rédaction ce soir marylène
iapichino nous propose un état des lieux
des sections féminines dans les clubs
locaux
rencontre avec ces équipes est aussi le
district de football des yvelines
reportage tous les mardis à magny les
hameaux et jusqu'à mi juin
les jeunes filles sont invités à
s'essayer au foot objectif recruter des
joueuses pour étoffer voir créer de
nouvelles équipes féminines le mani
football club et ses 400 licenciés s'est
lancé dans le football féminin cette
année 24 joueuses sont inscrits et ont
leurs créneaux d'entraînements dédié je
pensais pas que c'était bien parce qu'il
y avait qu à des garçons qui jouent et
et qui est défi face à zoug
nouveau c'est mon frère y regarder tout
le match à la télé et du coup ça m'a
donné envie de plus m'intéresser au
virus pour les motiver le club va les
amener au parc des princes assister au
match d'ouverture de la coupe du monde
féminine
le 7 juin prochain dans le district d
evelyne les féminines représente 6,2
pour cent des licenciés alors qu'elles
n'étaient que 3 2% lors de la saison
2013 2014
un effectif en croissance qui correspond
à la volonté de féminisation du football
du président et de son équipe
l'idée qui pour certains présidents ont
maintenant c'est de se dire bah il faut
peut-être que j'ai une équipe de
football garçons deux mois pour pouvoir
laisser de la place à la création d'une
équipe de filles ça il ya dix ans
c'était impensable en tout cas ce
n'était pas le cas
et maintenant l'idée est en train de
faire son chemin c'est que c'est pas
parce que les garçons jouent au foot
depuis toujours qu'il faut pas aussi
laisser un petit peu de place sur aux
joueurs seuls 37 clubs sur son 53 dans
les yvelines propose des sections
féminines pour les encourager le
district les aide en leur attribuant du
matériel mais plus que des joueuses dans
les yvelines
on souhaite également plus de formatrice
il se trouve que malheureusement nous
n'avons pas assez de d'éducatrice nous
avons beaucoup d'éducateurs qui se
former mais pas ses d'éducatrice une
formation d'éducatrice c'est gratuit
c'est gratuit c est payant pour les
messieurs
pour les hommes c'est gratuit pour les
femmes tendent district des yvelines
parce que j'ai depuis toujours parce que
c'est une façon d'inciter les
des filles à se former autre cheval de
bataille l'encadrement
sur les 153 club yvelinois 14 sont
présidées par des femmes
le district organise des journées femmes
franchissez la barrière pour encourager
les mamans un s'investir dans les clubs
de leur enfant pour mardi ou mercredi
prochain
il faut tout organiser pour que ce soit
bien fait parmi les quatorze présidents
de clubs dans les yvelines
mireille la faune et celle qui dirige
plus gros et l'encours et ses 800
licenciés après avoir inscrit ses deux
fils au club la mer s'investit pour
prendre de plus en plus de
responsabilités jusqu'à se retrouver à
la tête en juin dernier
au début c'est un challenge on se dise
qu'on va y arriver est ce qu'on va être
reconnue parce que les femmes dans le
foot c'est pas encore démocratisée mais
c'est passionnant
c'est passionnant et très enrichissant
et on travaille avec des personnes
dévouées qui sont passionnés par le
monde du football et des parents en
prime est de plus en plus la main à la
pâte
la première section féminine d'elancourt
a été créé il ya dix ans aujourd'hui
elles sont 62 licenciés le club compte
également des formatrices une arbitre
une quasi parité au sein de son conseil
d'administration
il est le prochain à recevoir le label
du foot féminin des mains ou président
du district
[Musique]
sur le green sont attendus de nombreux
sportifs de haut niveau le 26e trophée
sport passion se déroulera demain jeudi
16 m
oyu golf de feucherolles organisée par
sport passion communication sur ce
plateau origines gandolfini bonsoir vous
est la fondatrice et organisatrice de ce
trophée sport passion qui fête donc
cette année sa 26e édition
alors le principe c'est un trophée de
golf avec un parterre de sportifs de
haut niveau réunie alors rien que
l'année dernière étaient réunis au yukon
fait de feucherolles 11 médailles
olympiques 35 titres de champion du
monde
trente sept titres de champion d'europe
pourquoi les réunir ces sportifs de haut
niveau finalement quel est l'objectif de
cet événement ça date de 1994 à
s'adapter a longtemps je crois que le
l'envi que j'avais à ce moment là
c'était de réunir des sportifs de haut
niveau en fait moi j'adorais le sport et
j'avais envie de réunir des sportifs de
haut niveau sur un golf qui était un
sport que beaucoup de sportifs de haut
niveau pratiqué et leur faire faire une
compétition pour voir quel était le
sport qu'elle ait remporté ce trophée
que j'avais appelé le trophée sport
passion à ce moment là parce qu'il
faudrait trouver un nom générique qui
puisse réunir tout au début pendant les
premières années il n'y avait pas du
tout d'initiation donc il n'y avait que
des gaules des sportifs golfeurs voilà
et c'était le plaisir des rencontres
en fait je me disais peut-être qu'un
voile eux ne rencontre pas un basketteur
en valeur un beug beug clinton chose
pour monde y est c'était c'était ça
c'était les rencontres en fait j'ai
d'échanger sur leurs expériences
respectives au sport ou bien sûr
échanger sur leurs expériences mais
aussi créer
des projets ensemble de développer des
contacts du réseau
ce qu'on fait beaucoup maintenant est ce
qui se faisait pas beaucoup à l'époque
et c'était ça vraiment le concept était
de se dire que tu fasses du basket du
ski du sport automobile finalement
terrain sportif vous avez tous la même
passion qui est le sport et ben voilà
parlez vous et vous le disiez tout à
l'heure en coulisses et aussi de
décrocher une journée de devenir sur une
journée pour penser à autre chose que ça
sonne un peu du thon de sportif voilà
c'est alors c'est vrai que c'est encore
plus vrai aujourd'hui parce que avec des
réseaux sociaux où ils ont moins
l'impression finalement d'être loin les
uns des autres
parce que ils peuvent on peut tous se
suivre sur les réseaux sociaux et on a
l'impression de se voir finalement
chaque jour mais le message que je
l'aurais fait passer cette année c'est
de leur dire 'attendez coupé venez
passer une journée
parlez vous regardez vous et vous allez
voir que l'humain c'est quand même
important c'est tu le regardes les
sensations de sushis voilà et donc
c'était de redire cette journée là c'est
une journée magique pour je la considère
comme une journée magique
profitez-en respirer et profiter quoi
dans une ambiance festive c'est aussi le
credo de l'événement oui il ya eu des il
ya eu des éditions qui ont été
mémorables notamment avec luc alphand
qui était quand même voilà spécialisés
pour faire des ddd descendre des
escaliers en ski par exemple ou plonger
dans les bunkers avec les voiturettes de
golf ce qui était quand même pas
recommandée mais très très festive oui
ils sont on voit qu'il ya vraiment un
plaisir le moment du déjeuner par
exemple quand ils se retrouvent tous à
table et qu'on les voit finalement se
réunir par petits groupes avec les
invités qui sont là et qui les
connaissent pas et qui n'osent pas se
mettre avec eux les conversations
s'enchaînent et s'enclenche direct
ensemble il ya vraiment on sent un
plaisir d'être là et passer cette
journée et vous en parle d créée en 1994
ce trophée ce qu'il a il la gagne en
popularité ce qu'il a grandi ce que vous
avez réussi à constituer un socle de
fidèles des sportifs qui reviennent
chaque année
oui oui alors il y en a qui s'appelle
les membres fondateurs donc antoine
kombouaré par exemple dit le jour moi je
suis un membre fondateur
je prendrai alain roche qui est là cette
année ils étaient là la première édition
et je crois que s'il en a raté 2 3 c'est
vraiment parce qu'il pouvait pas être là
autrement il vient tous les ans eliane
et j'ai un sportif donc et françois
manche qui fait du hockey sur gazon il a
fait les 26 il va faire les 26 éditions
balland plus à chaque fois on ne confond
le haut le nomme parce qu'on s'est quand
même voilà exception dit chaque année
peut-être que tu m'as litres a pas
l'année prochaine mais bien sûr qu'il a
sa place pour être pour toujours quoi et
quelles sont les épreuves sportives qui
ont répondu présents là pour cette
invitation
alors cette année on a on à 73 sportif
là qu'ils se sont inscrits à aujourd'hui
donc ils sont tous internationaux des
anciens dont il ya des nouveaux par
exemple comme arthur 2 mai ce qui
n'était jamais venu donc il va venir
jean marc mormeck qui sera présent des
moins connus mais avec des palmarès
incroyable et on a à peu près un tiers
des sportifs qui sont en activité
donc on va avoir des judokas du canoë
du skiff il ya vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup sportifs présents et à la bombe
yannick noah sera là aussi je ferai tous
ces sites est là et il ya beaucoup de
sports différents tout 31 sport cette
année une volonté aussi chaque année
c'est qu'il ya un angle solidaire à ce
trophée les cette année vous allez
soutenir l'association solidarité laïque
juste avant de présenter l'association
c'est quelque chose d'important ça ce
côté solidaire pour le trophée sport
passion oui alors je voulais juste dire
une petite chose séquence est aperçu
avec le temps en fait que les sportifs
avaient des choses à dire ça veut dire
qu'il ya beaucoup de sportifs qu'ils
s'engagent donc je pense à yvan bourgnon
qui va venir qui s'engagent pour
nettoyage des océans
beaucoup de sportifs s'engage aussi pour
défendre des causes est donc pour moi je
me suis dit il faut que le trophée sport
passion soit suivent un sportif dans son
engagement soit s'engage sur une cause
aussi et donc c'est vrai que pour moi
c'était important que l'on puisse pas
faire passer un message
donc je me suis rapproché du conseil
départemental des yvelines puisqu'ils
sont présents sur cet événement là et je
leur ai demandé voilà il ya tellement de
d'associations comment je peux faire
quoi et ils m'ont recommandé solidarité
laïque puisque solidarité laïque en fait
est constitué de 50 et une organisation
qui travaille avec eux et chaque année
ils choisissent un projet et ils vont
défendre ce projet là et il change tous
les ans donc cette année on a choisi de
défendre le projet rentre et solidaire
et donc c'est donc je me suis petite
ardoise là comme ça rend très solidaire
et principes du coup c'est donc fournir
des fournitures scolaires en fait pour
des enfants de la réponse république
démocratique du congo pour cette année
donc on va demander à tous les
participants de venir avec des
fournitures scolaires et de les remettre
à solidarité laïque pour qu'ensuite
elles partent au congo une dernière
question qu'est ce qu'on peut vous
souhaiter pour ce 26e trophée sport
passion le soleil déjà c'est prévu
peut-être on va voir ça j'espère
j'espère ça peut vous souhaiter pour le
26 élèves et toujours de bonne humeur et
qu'à la fin de la journée 11 10 euros
c'était dur c'était fatigant mais qu'est
ce qu'on est heureux comme c'est sa
merci original dans dolphin d'être
cassée sur ce plateau fondatrice et
organisatrice de ce trophée sport
passion 26e édition au programme demain
jeudi 7 au yukon faisait feugerolles et
puis mercredi c'est un jour de sortie au
cinéma c'est le jour aussi de notre
petit tour dans les salles obscures du
territoire des films à la fiche de l'ujc
signé skywest c'est au micro de patrick
jacques de dixmude bonjour bienvenue
pour notre nouvelle semaine
cinématographique semaine un petit peu
spécial parce que cette semaine c'est
naturellement le lancement du festival
de cannes donc vous avez derrière moi la
fiche le nouveau jim jarmusch qui est
sorti hier et qui a fait les montées des
marches de cannes donc toute la semaine
va être marquée par des nouvelles
sorties pour tuer par les sorties de
cannes donc notamment vous allez
retrouver le nouveau film aussi de pedro
almodovar douleur et gloire qui sortira
uniquement vendredi en salle
vous retrouvez aussi de nouveau film de
jean reno s'écoute blog legacy or c'est
l'histoire d'un tueur à gages qui est à
la retraite et qui va reprendre du
service pour sauver une belle qui va
entre guillemets atterrir devant sa
porte
vous allez retrouver également deux
avant-premières john wick parabellum ou
donc c'est la suite des jeunes week
l'avant-première sera au vendredi vous
retrouvez également aussi une
avant-première dimanche ça pour les plus
jeunes téléspectateurs c'est ce taudis
qui raconte la gloire d'un petit chien
qui va devenir le héros de la première
guerre mondiale
et vous allez avoir aussi le dernier
film de charlize theron sédunois si tu
peux alors c'est l'histoire d'une femme
qui est destiné à de grandes destinées
pour la maison blanche américaine et qui
vont engager qu'il plume qui nettoie que
l'ancien personnes avec qui elle faisait
des cités dans ces zones
voilà un petit peu pour les grandes
nouveautés de cette semaine à alger
c'est sky bastille
[Musique]
et puis à noter côté cinéma nous serons
au festival de cannes pour suivre les
yvelinois de la croisette une série de
reportages à retrouver la semaine
prochaine dans ce journal la fin à du
7-8 journal rendez vous demain pour une
nouvelle édition d'information locale
belle soirée à tous
oh
[Musique]